저도 진심으로 이렇게 질문을 하신 분이 있어요.
저희 직원 20명이 똑같은 일을 하고 있는데
갑자기 한 사람이 AI를 가지고 엄청나게 속도를 10배, 20배로 올리니까
옆 사람들이 반칙한다고 그래요.
아니요. 너무 좋아요.
얘들아, 10배, 20배 해봐.
저희 식파 친구들은 지금 4, 5명 이상을 뽑아야 되는 상황인데
지금 이런 상황이라는 것은 AI를 도입하지 못한
부닥다리 기업이기 때문에 지금 이런 고민을 하는 겁니까?
아니, 일단 사장님부터 부닥다리잖아요.
내가 부닥다리 아니었으면 너를 뽑았을 것 같아요.
자, 2부에 소장님 나오셨습니다.
네, 안녕하십니까.
소장님 예전에 사실 저희 소금빵 AI 영상 만들어주시면서
그게 굉장히 핫했어요.
네, 맞아요.
소금빵 너무 맛있는데.
그런 재밌는 것들 오늘 또 한번 기대를 하고 있습니다.
그렇군요.
요즘에 유행하는 거 하나만 좀 보여드릴까요?
좋아요.
AI 쪽에서 또 그림 그리기 되게 유행하는 게 뭐냐면
이제 덕테이프라고 해가지고
체치 PT의 이미지 기능이 업데이트가 됐어요.
근데 이제 나노바나나를 이기려고 나온 게
이 체치 PT에서 만든 이미지 2인데
이 이름이 덕테이프인 이유가 뭐냐면
덕테이프.
예전에 보면 예술 작품 중에 그런 거 있어요.
바나나 있고 거기에다가 이렇게 은색 테이프 붙여.
테이프, 맞아.
그게 이제 덕테이프거든요.
그래가지고 얘네들이 이제 나노바나나잖아요.
바나나를 뒤엎을 정도로 이길 정도로.
바나나를 붙여버리겠다.
네, 그렇죠.
그렇게 해가지고 이제 이 이름을 덕테이프로 붙였는데
이게 이번에 나왔는데 진짜로 성능이 괜찮은 거예요.
그래서 어느 수준이냐.
요즘에 이제 AI가 개발세발 그림을 그릴 수 있을까?
개발세발?
할 수 있나?
이게 되기 시작합니다.
돼요?
네.
그래서 제가 방금 이 앞에서
유튜브 라이브 하시는 거 캡쳐를 했어요.
방금, 방금 사실.
네, 이런 식으로 프롬트를 주는 거예요.
위 이미지를 개발세발.
세상에서 가장 하찮은 선으로 그려줘.
우와, 이게 되나?
뭐 이런 식으로 시키는 거죠.
궁금하다.
그러면 AI가 이렇게 그립니다.
우와, 우와, 우와, 우와.
우와, 예쁘게 나오네.
그렇듯해.
그러니까 이게 지금 오히려 역으로 AI의 능력을 이제 보여주는 거예요.
귀엽다.
이거 쓰고 싶어, 로고로.
아니, 이거 저희 지금 굿즈 사업하려고
디자이너, 개발자 이런 거 다 생각하고 있었거든요.
그럼 여기 다 돌리면 되겠네.
그러니까 이...
죄송합니다.
그럼 우리 디자이너 퇴근하셨지?
이거 보면 안 돼.
그래서 오늘 무슨 얘기를 좀 드릴까 하다가.
제가 원체 말씀하신 대로 제가 이제 매주 뭐 AI 트렌드 얘기를 하니까.
네, 네.
그거 한번 엮어서 좀 제일 궁금해하실 만한 거를
액기스로.
제가 주제를 한 여덟 개 정도 뽑아왔어요.
아, 여덟 개요?
진짜요?
네.
알겠습니다.
그중에서 이제 원하시는 거 몇 개를 좀 오늘 한번 해보도록 할게요.
오, 대박.
네.
일단 그거 하기 전에.
소장님의 책이.
아, 책, 책, 아, 책 준비하려고.
아, 책, 책.
네.
피지컬 AI.
2016 통신의 선택.
의식가님, 이런 거 잘해주세요.
아, 감사합니다.
네.
제가 매주 했었던 방송들을 좀 정리를 하면 일단 저 정도의 키워드들이
좀 있고요.
조직의 변화.
진짜.
실제적으로 내가 잘릴 거냐, 말 거냐.
난 이게 로봇의 대체가 될 수 있냐, 없냐.
지금 대체할 것보다 제일 이슈가 이거, 이건데요.
뭐예요?
그 요즘에 그 블라인드 글 중에 제일 이슈가 되고 있는 게 프롬프트는
누구의 것인가.
오, 맞아.
이겁니다.
한번 슈카님 이 회사를 운영하시니까 한번 생각을 해보세요.
만약에 우리 슈카 친구들에 있는 어떤 사람이.
네, 네.
열심히 공부했어요.
그래가지고 나만의 AI 노하우가 생겼어요.
네, 네.
근데 그거를 이제 자기가 적용하기 시작해서.
그래서 슈카님이 이제 야, 너 AI 잘 쓰는 거 같은데 네가 만든 프롬프트
좀 좀 공유해라.
이랬더니 갑자기 성원이 싫은데요?
제 건데요?
제 거고 제가 열심히 노력해서 만든 건데 이걸 왜 공유해요?
그, 그러면 저는 네, 이렇게 얘기할 것 같습니다.
옛말에 그런 말이 있다.
같은 말이어도 고따구로 얘기하면 될 것도 안 돼요.
아, 태도의 문제.
아, 그럼.
말, 같은 말이어도 이쁘게 해야 된다는 말이 있어요.
가는 말이 좋아요.
공손하게 하면 괜찮아요?
보는 말에 가는 것도 있고.
네, 네.
원래 사람 간의 관계는 잘 얘기를 통해서 해야 되는데.
싸가지 이슈구나, 그거는.
아니, 고따구로 얘기를 하면은.
그러니까 이런 것들이 이제 실제 문제가 되는 거예요.
네.
왜냐하면 지금까지 우리가 AI를 기업에서 쓴다라고 하면 그냥 개인이 써서 열심히 하는 거 아닌가라고 했는데.
맞아.
이게 결국에 말씀하신 대로 기업 입장에서 보면 기업의 시간을 쓰는 거잖아요.
그렇죠.
그리고 예를 들면 요즘에 우리나라도.
전 세계적으로 AI를 잘 쓰게 하기 위해서, 동요하게 하기 위해서 기업에서 예를 들면 대회도 하고 여러 가지 상도 주고 막 그러고 있는데.
거기서 1등을 했는데 그럼 그거에 대한 리소스를 어떻게 되는 거냐라고 하는 것처럼 지금 이제 되게 화두가 되는 게 뭐냐면요.
우리가 지금까지는 프로그램을 만들 때는 코드 이런 게 중요했잖아요.
네.
그런데 요즘에는 오히려 코드를 짜는 것보다 이 프롬프트가 더 중요하다는 얘기를 하는 거예요.
그렇죠.
이 프롬프트를 써가지고 코드를 만들어 달라는 게 80% 이상으로 넘어가고 있는 상황이기 때문에.
그래서 그런 관점에서 기업은 도대체.
이거를 어떻게 관리해야 되고 어떤 구조를 가져야 되는가?
이런 것들이 지금 아마도 올 상반기부터 시작해서 이제 하반기까지 제일 큰 이슈 중에 하나가 될 거예요.
네.
그래서 이제 이런 것들과 함께 또 얘기할 만한 게.
쉐도우 AI라는 얘기가 있어요.
쉐도우 AI.
쉐도우 AI 뭐지?
몰컴 들어보세요.
몰컴.
몰래 컴퓨터요?
네.
몰컴처럼 몰 AI가 있는 겁니다.
아.
이거 있어.
네.
맞어.
왜 몰랐어요?
그냥 쓰면 되지?
지금은 슈카 님이 밖에 계시지만.
네.
증권사에 계신다고 생각해보세요.
증권사에서 인터넷에 연결이 안 되는 PC들이 있잖아요.
아니면 금융에 대한 여러 가지 망 분리 때문에.
네.
그런데 나는 AI를 갖고 예를 들면 클로드를 갖고 보고서를 쓰면 엄청나게 성과가 좋아요.
그런데 회사에서는 야, 보안 때문에 안 돼.
그러고 있어요.
그러면 어떻게 하실 거예요?
핸드폰으로 한 다음에 이거 보고 만들면.
그게 쉐도우 AI입니다.
아.
몰랐으면 몰래.
그거의 포인트는 그래, 내가 쓰더라도 회사에 데이터를 넣으면 안 돼.
있잖아요.
그런데 그렇게 쓰다 보면.
아.
나도 모르게.
이거 회사 문서 하나 넣으면 잘 나오는데.
이러다 보니까 거기서 오히려 전 세계적으로 보안 문제가 발생한다는 거예요.
아, 대박이다.
그런데 이런 것들이 이제 우리가 좀 잘 생각을 해봐야 된다는 겁니다.
이미 AI를 쓰는 것들이 대세가 됐는데.
네.
그 안에서 이렇게 AI를 오히려 몰래 써야 되는 상황들이 오면 이 두 가지 이슈가 아까 말한 대로 발생한다는 거예요.
하나는 오히려 야, 너 회사에서 얘기도 안 했는데 내가 열심히 했으니 이거는 내 거야라고 하는 쪽이 한편 있고.
한쪽에서는 아까 말씀드린 대로 야, 이렇게 되면 실제로 오히려 보안적 문제는 여기서 더 커진다는 거죠.
데이터를 들고 나가니까.
맞네.
지금 어떻게 보면 기업에서는 제일 큰 핵심의 이슈라고 볼 수 있을 것 같고요.
그다음에 이제 또 기업에서 최근에 되게 이슈가 되고 있는 것 중에 하나가 뭐냐면 우리가 이제 사람의 업무를 어떻게 평가할 것인가라고 하는 내용들이 있습니다.
이거는 이제 조금 히스토리를 넘어가면 2025년 CES 때 젠슨왕 형님께서 되게 의미심장한 얘기를 하나 하셨어요.
그런데 그거를 대부분의 사람들이 그냥 놓쳤는데 그게 뭐냐면.
이제 IT 부서가 HR 부서에 역할을 할 것이다.
이런 얘기를 했습니다.
HR 부서가 뭐 하는 거죠?
조직 관리하고 사람 관리하는 거잖아요.
그런데 이제 HR 부서에 힘이 있었던 이유는 신입사원이 뽑으면 신입사원을 어디에 배치시켜줄까인 거잖아요.
그런데 이제 우리가 일을 AI로 하잖아요.
AI로 할 때 사람이 AI를 무제한 쓰려면 뭐가 필요할까요?
맨날 우리가 이 투자 때 맨날 얘기하는 그게 있어야 된다.
팩토리 나오는 토큰이죠, 토큰.
토큰, 맞아. 토큰.
그럼 예를 들면 우리는 보통 대부분 다 이 AI를 정액제로 쓰잖아요.
그러니까 예를 들면 한 달에 뭐 2만 원 내거나 20만 원, 3만 원, 10만 원 내면 이렇게 딱 정해주는 대로인데
기업에서는 보통 그렇게 쓸 수가 없어요.
기업은 종량제로 쓴단 말이에요.
그럼 생각을 해보면 우리 회사에 이번 달에 쓸 수 있는 토큰이 예산상 100만 토큰이에요.
그럼 그 100만 토큰을 어느 부서에 주느냐가
권력이다.
권력인 거죠, 정확하게 말하면.
대박, 대박.
그리고 반대로 말하면 토큰이 배분되는 걸 사는 거예요.
사람으로 비유를 하면 AI가 이제는 직원처럼, 비서처럼 같이 일하는 거잖아요.
그거를 관리하는 사람의 역할이 이거 거의 뭐 조직에서 이제는 분배해주는 역할이 아니냐 이런 얘기가 지금 나오고 있는 상황이에요.
예산 편성, 예산 편성.
그렇죠.
올해 초에 우버에서 실은 이 직원들한테 AI를 무제한으로 쓸 수 있게 하겠다.
너네들 이거 쓰면 좋으니까 토큰 줄게 이랬거든요.
1분기도 안 끝났는데 1년 예산을 다 썼어요.
그래서 우리 더 이상 못 써 이런 일들이 발생하고 있는 거예요.
그럼 이제 역으로 되게 재미있었던 현상들이 생긴 게
전 세계적인 빅테크 기업들이 이 사람을 평가할 때 너는 토큰을 얼마큼 썼냐를 갖고 능력을 평가하기 시작했어요.
많이 쓴 게 능력이 좋은 건가요?
왜냐하면 AI를 그만큼 잘 쓰거나 AI를 갖고 뭔가를 만들어냈다는 거예요.
왜냐하면 토큰을 많이 쓰려면 글 쓰는 것만으로는 잘 안 돼요.
예를 들면 내가 그걸 가지고 코딩을 하거나 프로그램을 만들거나.
그런데 그런 것들이 되다 보니까 또 어떤 문제가 생겼는데 또 이런 사람이 생겨요.
AI한테 야, 그냥 네가 토큰 최대한 많이 써.
토큰 최대한 많이 쓰는 걸 네가 돌려.
지불이 1억 장 그려.
그러니까요. 아니, 목표를 주는 것도 아니에요.
그냥 무의미한 행동을 계속 시키면서 토큰을 계속 소비하게 시키는 역할들까지 되는 겁니다.
기업에서 AI를 어떻게 적용할 것인가와 관련된 수많은 지금 이슈들이 좀 생기고 있는 상황이고요.
그럼 이제 개인 입장에서는 실제로 AI로 날아다니는 사람들과 그리고 그것 때문에 또 고민하는 사람들이 상당히 많이 생기기 시작했어요.
예를 들면 이분이 원체에 유명하신 분이라.
나중에 검색하시면 나와요.
이분이 광진구청의 7년 차 공무원분이신데 이분이 어떤 분이냐면 원래는 그냥 공무원이에요, 공무원.
그런데 법령 정보를 계속 찾아야 되니까 너무 힘든 거예요.
이분은 원래 AI를 쓰는 분이 아닌데 2025년 10월부터 써가지고 그 내용을 갖고 국가 법령 정보를 쉽게 말해서 클로즈한테 한 방에 가져오게 하는 어떤 MCP라고 하는 허브 같은 거를 만들자라는 걸 본인이 그냥 AI로 배워서 한 거예요.
그랬더니 이게 지금 나와가지고 이 사람이 엄청나게 뜨기도 하고요.
제가 또 재미있게 본 사례 중에 하나가 고졸 비전공이고 크래프톤에서 AI 해코통 2등 하신 분이 있는데 이분이 상당히 흥미로운 게 이분은 원래는 AI 전공자가 아니니까 문서상, 서류상 시험에서는 백지를 내셨대요.
그런데 실제로 프로그램을 만드는 거를 오히려 잘한다는 거예요.
이분 봤어, 맞아.
그런데 이게 되게 재미있는 게 뭐냐면 오히려 이분이 자기가 AI에 대한 거나 이런 내용을 잘 모르니까 AI는 처음부터 모르는 거예요.
네.
그래서 물어보면서 해서 더 잘 나왔다는 거예요.
오히려 약간 문과 출신이고 잘 모르는데 되더라.
그러니까 편견이 없는 거죠.
예를 들면 투자로 생각을 하면 투자가 내 방법이 있어라고 하는데 이분은 그런 게 하나도 없으니까.
미니처럼 그냥 미수로 그냥 시작을 하는 거야.
미니님 같은 거죠.
그러니까 쉽게 말해서 영상으로 투자를 배우거나 이런 것처럼 이분은 그냥 AI한테 물어본 거예요.
야, 나 이거 하고 싶은데 이거 어떻게 하면 돼?
그래서 이게 어떻게 보면 기존에 생각할 수 없었던 새로운 시대와 새로운 세대들이 등장하는 포인트다라는 거예요.
그런데 여기서 이제 중요한 게 있죠.
이렇게 한 사람이 여러 가지를 하게 되는 사람이 조직에 있으면 어떻게 될까라는 것도 생각을 해봅니다.
좋죠, 왜?
부릴 것 같은데.
그러니까 이게 슈카 님은 우리 조직을 이끌고 계시니까 좋다라는 건데 만약에 예전에 금융권에 계실 때 생각을 해보시면 돼요.
예를 들면 영업을 했던 사람인데 어, AI를 했더니 내가 마케팅도 할 수 있을 것 같고 디자인도 할 수 있을 것 같고 다 하기 시작을 합니다.
그러면 원래 디자인 부서에 있던 사람이 뭐라고 그럴까요?
내 영역이 나오지 말라고.
내 영역이 나오죠.
아니면 원래 마케팅팀에 있던 사람이 그냥 월권 하는 거 아니야?
월권이지.
이렇게 될 수도 있는 거예요.
비슷한 현상이 생기는 게 제가 요즘에 대기업 임원들 강의 질문을 봤을 때 제일 놀라웠던 것 중에 하나가 뭐냐면 저한테 진심으로 이렇게 질문을 하신 분이 있어요.
사장님 그런데 저희 직원 20명이 똑같은 일을 하고 있는데 갑자기 한 사람이 AI를 가지고 엄청나게 속도를 10배, 20배로 올리니까 옆 사람들이 반칙한다고 그래요.
아니요.
너무 좋아요.
사장님 입장에서는 그렇지.
얘들아 10배, 20배 해봐.
영어 하루에 왜 꼭 하나를 올려야 되니.
한국에 못 올릴 한 번 없다.
오히려 작은 기업들은 그게 야, 이거 기회가 된다.
한 명이서 이렇게 할 수 있다.
그러니까 한 명의 역량이 증폭되고 있는데 대기업 입장에서는 그렇게 됐을 때 우리 칸칸이 부서들에서 하는 것들이 어떻게 될 것인가라고 하는 것들에 대해서 되게 정면적인 도전을 받고 있어요, 지금.
그래서 그런 부분에 있어서 방향성을 제대로 주지 않은 상황에서 AI 써.
그러면 지금 그렇게 잘하시는 분들이 오히려 튕겨나갑니다, 요즘 보면.
그래서 이런 변화들이 상당히 좀 흥미롭다.
사장님, 현실과 친구들은 지금도 사람을 구하고 사람이 없어서 난리거든요.
지금 한 4, 5명 이상을 지금 뽑아야 되는 상황인데 지금 이런 상황이라는 것은 AI를 도입하지 못한 그런 어떻게 보면 구닥다리 기업이기 때문에 지금 이런 고민을 하는 겁니까?
아니죠.
한 명을 뽑으면 지금 10명, 20명을 한다는데.
구닥다리인가요?
지금 우리 친구들이 지금 구닥다리 식으로 AI 제대로 활용하는 거예요.
아니죠.
지금 AI 제대로 활용하지 못해요.
아니, 일단 사장님부터 구닥다리잖아요.
그러면 뱅킹 같은 것도 잘 안 봤을 거고.
내가 구닥다리 아니었으면 너를 뽑았을 것 같아요.
그다음에 뭐 또 아까 아마 네 님 제일 궁금해하실 거.
오픈 AI랑 구글 엔트로피 얘기를 좀 해보도록 할게요.
이 오픈 AI가 되게 여러 가지 말이 나오고 있어요.
맞아요.
그러니까 이게 왜 그러느냐.
오픈 AI는 원래 옛날부터도 항상 위기론이 많았죠, 위기론.
그런데 이번에는 조금 다른 것 같아요.
왜냐하면 이게 채찍 PT가 주간활성자 사용 목표가 미달성되기 시작했어요.
그러니까 이렇게 되니까 이제 문제가 되기 시작을 하는 거죠.
AI의 구조.
그러니까 제가 이제 피지컬 AI에서 계속 구조에 대한 되게 요즘에 생각을 많이 하게 된 게 이게 과연 계속 돌아갈 수 있는 구조인가라는 생각을 해야 된다는 거죠.
그러니까 우리가 이른바 플랫폼 비즈니스에서의 스타트업의 성공 방정식은 뭐였냐면 한계비용 제로 혹은 한계비용체감의 법칙이라는 거에서 시작이 됐어요.
이게 뭐냐면 우리 초기 비용만 잘 세팅이 되면 그러면 회원수 모이면 광고비, 조회수 등등으로 돈이 쌓이니 초기 투자만 잘해주고 시간이 지나면 우리가 이제 큰 돈으로 보상을 해드릴 거예요가 예전의 그림이었잖아요.
그래서 그게 이제 한계비용체감이라는 거예요.
그러니까 오히려 사람들이 늘어나고 서비스가 커지더라도 추가적인 비용이 덜 든다.
그런데 생성형 AI는 이게 안 통하는 거죠.
쓰면 쓸수록 돈이 더 나가.
맞아요.
쓰면 쓸수록 돈이 더 나가니까.
네.
그러니까 이거는 냉정하게 말하면 되게 유통비즈니스랑 비슷한 거예요.
쉽게 말해서 물건을 떼왔는데 물건 원가도 못 주게 생겼다라고 얘기를 하는 거예요.
이게 구독자가 빠지는 거예요? 아니면 목표를 너무 높게 잡아서 그걸 못 채운 거예요?
정확하게 말하면 구독자가 느는 속도가 엔트로픽 때문에 줄어들기 시작하는 거예요.
유통비즈니스랑 비슷하다는 게 어쨌든 물건을 팔려면 물건을 사와야 되잖아요.
그렇죠.
물건을 사오는 게 지금 보면 데이터센터 비용이란 말이에요.
그런데 데이터센터 비용을 이렇게 되면 못 낼 수도 있겠는데?
그런데 이게 문제가 뭐냐면 오픈 AI가 무너지는 게 오픈 AI만의 문제면 상관이 없는데 만약에라도 오픈 AI가 삐끗했다.
이거는 그냥 지금 우리가 말하는 생성형 AI, AI 들어간 모든 회사들이 거의 주가가 박살이 나는 이슈가 될 수 있다는 거죠.
오픈 AI만 망하는 건 아니겠죠.
그렇죠.
엔비디아, 다이아몬드, 오라클.
이제 그런 상황에서 엔트로픽은 또 어떻게 되느냐.
지금 연간 환산 매출이 계속 올라가고 있고 기업 고객이 늘어나고 있거든요.
네.
기업이 늘어나니까 엔트로픽은 좋기만 하냐?
아니에요.
왜요?
얘네는 뭐가 문제냐면 아까 말한 물건으로 비교를 해볼게요.
지금 이 동네에 내가 팔 수 있는 물건이 1,000개가 있어요.
그런데 1,000개 중에 저기는 박리다매를 해.
그래서 저기가 800개를 사갔어요.
그런데 우리 200개를 갖고 하고 있는데 200개를 사온 다음에 이거의 가치를 엄청 높여서 되게 비싸게 팔고 있었단 말이에요.
그런데 여기에 막 사람이 몰려.
그런데 이제 200개보다 더 많은 수를 사람들이 원하는 거예요.
네.
그래서 우리가 100개를 가지고 왔는데 그 다음에 가져온 100개가 퀄리티가 안 나오는 거예요.
승이 안 차.
승이 안 차거나 이게 옛날 만큼 안 되는 거야.
그리고 사람들이 계속 몰리는데 감당이 안 되기 시작하니까 얘네들이 무슨 생각을 하냐면
그러면 우리가 200개 정도 할 수 있는 예산이니까 이거를 좀 싼 버전을 만들거나 약간 옛날보다 퀄리티를 좀 떨어뜨리고 여러 개를 쓰자라고 했더니
그게 계속 쓰는 사람들이 티가 난 거예요.
딱 걸렸어.
그래서 예를 들어서 지금 무슨 일이 발생하느냐.
예전에는 클로드가 거의 무조건 최강입니다.
예선도 아니죠.
1, 2주 전까지만 해도 클로드가 최강입니다 이랬는데 요즘 클로드 코드를 계속 쓰다 보면 얘가 뭐라고 그러냐면 진짜 그만하세요.
이런 얘기를 해요.
진짜입니다.
계속 쓰다 보면.
적당히 하라.
적당히.
AI가 여기까지만 하셔도 될 것 같아요.
그 정도 하자.
그런데 저 그거 느낀 게 AI랑 채팅 치다 보면 옛날에는 이거 궁금하지 않으세요 막 이랬거든요.
그런데 이제는 이렇게 하면 해결되셨죠.
그럼 이만.
약간 이런 느낌으로 마무리를 자꾸 하더라고요.
그렇죠.
맞아요.
이 녀석들이 이번에 이제 엔트로픽에서 잠깐 이게 나왔다가 욕을 하도 먹어서 이제 없앴는 건데 이제 엔트로픽의 요금제가 보면 20달러짜리 100달러짜리 200달러짜리가 있거든요.
20달러짜리에서도 AI로 코딩하고 이런 게 된단 말이에요.
그런데 갑자기 20달러 요금제에서 클로드 코드 쓰는 게 잠깐 며칠 동안 사라진 적이 있어요.
그러니까 이제 20달러짜리 이거 못 쓰게 할 거야라고 요금제를 바꿔버렸던 거예요.
그러니까 또 전 세계가 난리가 났었습니다.
그런 이슈들이 있는데 오히려 오픈 AI는 코딩이 안 돼요.
오픈 AI는 코딩하는 코덱스라는 게 성능이 계속 좋아지고 있으니까 지금 오히려 아이러니한 게 성능 자체는 오픈 AI가 그래도 요즘에 다시 좀 좋아지고 있는데
진짜요?
돈은 지금 떨어지고 있고.
클로드가 그냥 무조건 잘하는 게 또 아니었네요.
또 왔다리 갔다리 하고 있는 거네요.
그렇죠.
왔다리 갔다리.
왜냐하면 얘네는 소수 정예로 되게 비싼 모델을 만들던 회사였어요.
클로드는.
그래서 심지어 오픈 AI의 샘 알트먼은 맨날 엔트로픽 할 때 저 부자들만을 위한 AI 서비스 만드는 놈들 이러면서 맨날 욕을 했었거든요.
그렇다.
그래서 얘네들이 이제 계속적으로 잘 되니까 그 부분에서 이제 감당이 안 되기 시작을 하는 거죠.
그래서 이것 때문에 최근에 보셨겠지만 구글의 클라우드를 저 엔트로픽이 쓰기로 한 거죠.
그래서 이제 엔트로픽이 되게 특이하게 된 게 저 엔트로픽은 이제 리소스를 아마존 것도 갖다 쓰고 엔비디아 것도 갖다 쓰고 구글 TPU까지 갖다 쓰기 시작했어요.
그러니까 이거는 이제 어떻게 보면 그만큼 이 AI 시장에 여전히 시장에 투자될 돈들이 여전히 많이 필요하다.
왜냐하면 플레이어들이 뭔가 물건을 더 만들고 싶다.
클라우드가 부족한 거예요. 클라우드가.
그러니까 클라우드를 쓰는데 이 조건이 얼마나 이제 이 엔트로픽한테 빡세냐면 예를 들면 똑같은 클라우드 서비스라도 이게 엔비디아의 GPU 안에서 돌아갈 때의 세팅하고
그다음에 이 구글 TPU에서 돌아가는 세팅하고 이런 게 다 달라야 돼요.
그런데 그러면 엄청 귀찮고 복잡한 일이잖아요.
그런데 그걸 감내하고서라도 지금 쓰는 거예요.
그런데 이렇게 되면 구글 입장에서는 또 뭐가 좋냐면 전 세계에서 제일 지금 AI 쪽에서 잘 나온다고 생각하는 엔트로픽이 자기네들이.
네.
그래서 우리한테 칩도 써주기 시작을 하니까.
어머.
그렇게 되면 저 엔트로픽 입장에서는 역으로 이게 잘 되면 야 우리는 어떤 칩을 갖다줘도 다 쓸 수 있어라는 게 되는 거고.
구글 입장에서는 봐봐 구글 재미나이도 구글 TPU 쓰지.
지금 메타도 TPU 쓰지.
엔트로픽도 쓰지.
그러니까 우리가 짱이야.
지금 이렇게 얘기할 수 있는 상황들이 되고 있는 거죠.
짱이다.
네.
그래서 그런 관점으로 보면 단순한 모델 싸움이 아니라 돈 싸움 유통 싸움이 어떻게 될 것이냐.
그리고 그 밑에 있는 애들이 어떻게 될 것이냐를 보는 게 좋고요.
그래서 결론은.
우리는 반도체가 다다.
그렇죠.
어디든 어디든 다 쓴다.
왜냐하면 이제 이게 또 되게 중요한 게 엔트로픽의 보고서에 뭐가 있냐면.
에이전트 에이전트 얘기를 하잖아요.
에이전트는 되게 특이한 게 AI가 팀을 짜기 시작을 하거든요.
그런데 AI가 에이전트로 팀을 짜서 움직이면 기존보다 토큰 사용량이 최대 20배 이상 들어요.
그럼 똑같은 명령을 시켰을 때 얘가 팀을 짜서 할 때 토큰을 20배 이상 쓴단 말이에요.
그럼 그만큼 당연히 돈이 많이 들겠죠.
그럼 그만큼 당연히 다 데이터 센터가 필요하고 그만큼 GPU TPU 다 필요하고 그만큼 HBM이 필요하겠죠.
오히려 맨날 이제 한 1년 전부터 이제 클로드 엔트로픽의 보고서들을 보면 다 일괄적으로 얘기하는 게 지금 오히려 카펙스를 너무 과소평가한다.
훨씬 더 들어갈 게 많다라는 겁니다.
그럼 이제 이쯤에서 우리는 고민을 해야 될 게 그럼 투자를 통해서 돈을 벌 것이냐.
토큰이 늘어나면서 내 일자리가 지금 위협받는 거라 우리가 어떻게 트레이드 오프 할 것이냐.
더 사라.
더 사. 안 되겠다.
내가 더 사는 거 필요 없지?
자네가 더 사야 될 것 같아.
어떻게. 어떻게.
일자리가 위험해진대요.
아니 그러면 저도 AI 공부해가지고 그럼 제가 제 AI 에이전트 부리면서 그냥 사업하면 되는 거 아니에요?
아니 그러니까 상상을 해보면.
소장님 애들이 키우면 나가는 현상에 대한 대처법은 없습니까?
그건 어떻게 해야 돼요?
그러면 결론은 뭐냐면 슈카님이 AI 에이전트를 같이 이용하시면 됩니다.
아 사람 말고?
맞아요.
아니 그런 거 할 줄 몰라요.
AI 에이전트 부릴 줄 아세요 근데?
맨날 무료로 쓰는데 AI 에이전트로 어떻게 불려.
나도 이번에 광고 받아서 다 돌려봤어요.
지금 약간 들어보니까 막 요즘에 문과분들 이과분들 이런 거 다 구분 없이 다 그냥 코드 만들고 막 이틀만 배우면 다 한다고 하더라고요.
그러면 아 이걸로 약간 내 사업해야지.
이런 사업분들이 진짜 많이 생길 것 같아요.
직장인분들.
그렇죠.
근데 이제 여기서 되게 좀 맥락에서 중요한 포인트를 또 말씀을 드릴게 이렇게 해서 실제로 비즈니스를 할 수는 있는데요.
네.
저는 이게 보안 이슈로 이제 연결이 됩니다.
저도 이제 AI로 홈페이지를 만들었거든요.
근데 이제 그거를 실제로 저희 회사 홈페이지로 적용하려고 그랬더니 저희 회사에 또 이제 경력이 되게 많으신 부사장님이 계세요.
근데 그분이 김 소장 이거 김 소장님 만든 걸로 하다가 만약에 보안의 이슈가 터져서 게시판에 이상한 글들이 올라오기 시작하면 누가 책임질 거야? 이러는 거예요.
제가 책임질 수가 없는 거죠.
그러게요.
그래서 업체 쓰는 거야.
그래서 외주를 쓰거나 그래서 담당자가 있는 거야.
아.
그런 얘기를 하는 거죠.
여전히 책임을 져야 될 영역들에서.
그럼 거기서 조회수 잘 안 나오면 AI를 까야겠니? 너를 까야겠니?
그렇지.
조회수가 잘 안 나오고 재미가 없어요.
광고가 잘 안 붙어?
그렇지.
그러면 누구를 불러다가 뭐라고 얘기했어요?
바로 니니유.
바로 쪼이티 까야지.
그럼.
용도가 다 있는 거라니까.
그때 쪼이티가 깔 때 마음속으로 아우 저 새끼 또 그런데 그렇게 생각하지 말고 그래서 내가 돈을 받는구나.
이게 내 월급 값이구나.
이게 내 역할이요.
내 역할이요.
하는 거예요.
맞긴 해.
그런데 AI 시대에 없어지지 않을 최고의 직업 중에 하나.
대관 업무.
대관?
물건 빌리는 대관 말고 예를 들면 가서 이거 써봐 써봐.
아.
아싸.
나는 이렇게 인사하더라도 누군가 이렇게 인사해 줘야 될 거 아니에요
.
그렇지.
그거구나.
내가 그런데 그런 것도 기가 막히게 잘 알아.
기가 막히지.
그래서 뽑은 거야.
그런 관점으로 보면 결국엔 그럼 지금의 AI 시대를 20대들이 어떻게
봐야 되는가.
그리고 보면 일단은 투트랙이 있는 것 같아요.
투트랙이.
맞지.
그리고 또 조금은 서비스라도 움직이면 거기서 메이크 머니가 되는 게
있어요.
제일 대표적으로 제 주변에 이른바 바이브 코딩을 통해서 돈을 꽤
잘 벌고 있는 친구가 있거든요.
어떻게 하는 거지.
그 친구가 뭘 만들었냐면 AI 기반 에 사주 서비스를 만들었어요.
그거 좋아.
돈이 엄청 잘 벌려.
그런데 그걸로 돈을 어떻게 벌죠 .
그러니까 이렇게 하는 거예요.
hpt로 사주 보면 잘 안 맞는 게 있으니까.
맞아요.
그거를 AI 엔진을 갖고 온 다음에 또 이 분은 또 되게 대단한 게 이
분의 부모님이 역술가예요.
역술가의 도메인 지식을 가져와 가지고.
역수죠.
최적화를 한 거예요.
그렇게 해가지고 AI인데 물어보면 일단 잘 맞아.
그런데 잘 맞는데 이게 단순히 사주 딸깍딸깍 서비스가 아니라 대화
형으로 되어 있다 보니까 사람도 그렇잖아요.
한 번 딱 맞으면 그다음부터 이것 저것 막 물어보잖아요.
맞아요.
많이 물어볼 때 과금을 시켰는데 그랬더니 이게 일 매출이 많이 찍
힐 때는 개인이고 2명이서 하거든 요.
디자이너랑.
일 매출이 1000만 원 이상 그냥 막 나오는 거예요.
자기도 이 매출이 이렇게 나와서 너무 놀랐는데.
그래서 이걸 키우려고 봤더니 처음부터 다시 다 뜯어고쳐야 되는
거야.
왜냐하면 이게 그냥 몇 명이 재미있게 쓸 때는 상관이 없는데 이걸 만약에
글로벌 서비스에서 뒷단에다가 데이터도 넣는 구조도 만들고 시스템
화를 하고 이럴 때 처음부터 다시 다 만들어야 되는 거죠.
그러니까 결국 여기서 말씀드릴 수 있는 시사점이 내가 아이디어로
빠르게 창업을 해서 빠르게 돈 벌 수 있는 건 이제 가능하다.
좋은 아이디어 좋은 맥락이 있다면 단 그걸 시스템화하거나 어떤 기업
파일 때는 여전히 여러 가지 전통적인 코딩이거나 어떠한 접근이 있거나
접근들이 필요하다라는 거예요 .
그래서 이제 예전에는 내가 예를 들면 공모전을 했거나 뭐를 해가지고
나의 레퍼런스를 써서 대기업에 가는 구조였다면 지금은 내가 ai
를 갖고 몇 원이라도 벌어볼 수 있는 서비스를 하는 게 그게 어떻게
보면 나의 어떤 경쟁력이 될 수 있다는 거죠.
경력 쓸 때도 어디서 일했다가 아니고 내가 어떤 서비스를 만들어서 돈을
벌었다.
이게 되게 획기적이겠다.
그래서 실제로 요즘에 해외에 있는 빅테크 기업들은 뭘 물어보기 시작
했냐면 면접을 할 때 너 지금 에이전트
몇 개 돌렸어.
몇 개 돌리고 있어.
라는 걸 물어보기 시작해요.
너는 어떤 에이전트를 갖고 있니 너는 지금 ai랑 뭘 하고 있니 얼마
큰 포큰을 썼니 라는 걸 물어보면서 그걸 갖고 이제 경력을 쌓기 시작
하고요.
그래서 이런 형태들로 내가 경험 을 쌓고 그걸 통해서 어떠한 변화
를 얻거나 아니면 또 좋은 기회가 생기면 들어가는 형태들이 여전히
필요하다는 거예요.
왜냐하면 아직은 조직이 그렇게 바뀌지 않았으니까.
제가 이렇게 보이지만 하고 싶은 게 많고 이상한 아이디어가 많이
있는 사람이거든요.
만화 채널도 만드셨거든요.
예전에 이 시간만 있으면 ai로 이거 하나 만들면 좀 대박이겠다.
라는 생각을 또 한 게 있어요.
뭔가요 뭔가요.
매주 뭔가 생겨요.
매주.
그러니까 맨날 사업 방향이 맨날 바뀌어요.
맨날 바뀌다니.
맨날 바뀌어.
나이가 드니까 새로운 게임을 하는데 어려운데 찾아보니까 귀찮아요
.
게임하려고.
이게 왜냐하면 그리고 옛날에는 애들이 다 글로 썼어요.
이거를.
그럼 빨리빨리 보면 팁이 이거구나 금방 알았는데 요즘엔 애들이 팁
을 영상으로 만들어요.
그렇지.
야.
10분 20분 짜리씩.
언제 보고 앉아있냐.
어디쯤에 있는 거야.
이거 물론 아래에 ai 요약도 있긴 한데.
그래서 ai로 옆에서 내가 게임할 때 딱 켜놓으면 그렇게 하는 거 아닌데
.
텐 평평 궁.
야 이거 옆에서.
괜찮다.
괜찮지.
캐릭터가.
100개예요.
100개.
그 얘기해주면.
아니 이게 어렵다니까.
근데 죄송한데 소장님 리액션이 오.
왜 어려워.
소장님.
전 세계에 게이머가 몇 명인지 아시겠죠.
전 세계에 게이머가 몇 명인지 아세요 지금.
아니 아니 그게 아니라 왜냐면.
이 게임을 무시하시는 것입니까.
아닙니다.
그게 아니고 너무 늦은 아이디어 달린 얘기를 하고 있어서.
진짜 있어요 혼수충 ai.
아니 재미나이도 그렇고 요즘에 캡쳐 스마트폰 캡쳐하면 네모 떠는 거
아시죠.
거기에서 예를 들면 이 상황에서 어떻게 해 라고 하면 얘가 얘기해
주는 게 이미 작년부터 구글에서 발표한 시나리오에 있고.
근데 그거는 슈카님의 맥락은 아니라는 거예요.
왜냐면 스팀에서 이것저것 많이 한.
할 때마다 다 쳐줘야 돼.
옆에 그냥 채팅처럼 떠 있고 내가 뭐 할 때마다.
방법이 있어요.
뭐요.
방송을 켜고 게임을 하면 되잖아요 .
그러면 실제 사람들이 무료로 혼수를 해 줘요.
수만 혼수를 들으면서 하라고.
무료로.
그럼 박제되잖아.
아 그래서.
저놈 게임 못하네.
깨발 못이네.
스팀에 있는 회사들하고 풍미비테크 들하고 그런 데이터에 대한 도메인
을 할 겁니다.
왜냐면 이것 좀 오늘 되게 재밌는 기능이 하나 나와서 또 하나 보여
드릴게요.
구글 재미나이에 새로운 기능이 탑재가 하나 됐어요.
이게 뭔지 아세요 처음에 재미나이 에 가서 예를 들면 토익 800점 대비용
연습 문제 10개 만들어줘 이거를 그냥 시켜도 되는데 그냥 시키면
잘 안 될 때가 있어서 캔버스를 누르고 시키잖아요.
그러면 이 녀석이 이런 형태로 문제가 나와요.
이거는 지금 이미지 파일이잖아요 .
이게 왜 생겼는지 아세요 엊그저 께 구글에서 이제 우리나라에 와서
발표를 할 때 뭘 얘기를 했냐면 ybm하고 구글이 손을 잡았어요.
아 진짜로.
그래서 지금 이 토익 문제 연습 만들어조라고 하면 이게 ybm 문제
사전에서 나오는 거예요.
그러면 이런 식으로 이제 공부든 뭐든 ai 회사들이 도메인 데이터
와 제휴를 하기 시작을 하는 겁니다.
아니 제가 원래 투자자산원 용서 따려고 그 5만 원인가 비싼 책 샀
거든요.
이제 그런 거 안 사고 그냥 재미나이 한테 문제 만들어 달라고 하면 되
겠네요.
2년간 못 따고 있어요.
2년간.
야 그 투은사 하나 따라 그랬더니 페이지 하나를 못 넘겼어.
학습지는 진짜 다 망하는 거 아니에요 .
그러니까 이게 되게 놀라운 게 뭐냐면 그냥 토익 문제 만들어줘
가 아니라 이런 식으로 800점 대비용 연습 문제.
그래서 이렇게 해서 풀면 정답이다 뭐다 힌트 보기까지 이렇게 다 되는데
이게 되는 이유가 이게 단순히 ai 로 되는 게 아니라 데이터를 가지고
있는 회사랑 실제 제휴해서 만들기 시작을 했다는 거거든요.
그래서 말씀하신 것처럼 게임들도 그런 식으로 데이터가 제휴가 될
건데 이런 변화들이 있을 때 아까 처럼 보면 우리는 뭘 해야 되는가
를 생각을 해봐야겠죠.
예를 들면은 이제 우리가 온라인 교육이 다 생기면.
이제 오프라인 학원이 없어질 거라고 생각을 했는데 안 없어졌잖아요
.
그리고 되게 재밌는 것 중에 하나가 그중에서 되게 좀 틈새 비즈니스
지만 뭘 했던 사람들이 있냐면 온라인 수업을 잘 안 듣는 친구들한테
쫓아가서 선생님이 너 이거 왜 안 들어.
아 오프라인으로.
오프라인으로.
콘텐츠는 온라인에 있는데 오프라인 에서 관리를 해주는 이런 비즈니스
들을 또 해서 또 빈틈의 사업이 나왔 거든요.
그런 형태들로 ai 변화를 보면서 계속 좀 생각을 하고 싶다.
잡돌이 서비스.
제가 또 사업 아이템이 또 있는데 .
또 있어요.
네.
국민 취미 중에 하나가.
국민 취미.
낚시잖아요.
네.
낚시 인구 엄청 늘었어요.
그래요
근데 낚시를 가면은 특히 민물낚시 를 가면은 어디가 포인트인지가
잘 몰라요.
지금 날씨가 이렇고 습도가 이렇 고 시간이 여기니까 요쯤에서
하는 게 제일 확률이 높습니다라고 .
지금 필요하다니까 한 번 안 되면 2박 3일이 꽉 나요.
저기 구글 연락하셔서 투자 좀 받아 보세요.
알파고 낚시 버전.
100% 삽니다.
아 근데 이런 시대에 스타님이 진짜 돈 잘 버실 수도 있을 것 같아요
.
네.
아이디어가 어차피 사람이 되는 거 잖아요.
맞아요.
그래서 진짜로 이제 ai 시대에 뭐가 중요하냐 그러면 결국에는 이런
사람들 궁금한 게 많거나 세상에 불만이 많거나
그 사람도 되게 중요해요.
세상에 불만이 많아야 뭔가 나와 .
그런 것들을 갖고 계속 쿵시렁 쿵시렁 쿵시렁 쿵시렁 쿵시렁 쿵시렁
쿵시렁 하는 사람.
이런 사람도 잘 봅니다.
왜냐면 쿵시렁 쿵시렁 쿵시렁 해야 그 쿵시렁을 ai 그대로 쓸 수 있거든
.
아 진짜.
그러니까 슈카님에게 제일 중요한 건 누군가가 옆에서 ai 마이크 모드
켜놓고 계속 쿵시렁 쿵시렁 쿵시렁 쿵시렁 하는 거를 ai가 듣고 바로
해결할 수 있게.
아 그럼 제가 해드릴게요 라고 하면 ai를 붙여주시면 됩니다.
근데 ai 마이크 모드를 켜줄 사람이 필요한 거죠.
아 그거를 또 본인이 못 키시니까 .
본인이 못 하시니까.
와 오늘 얘기하다 보니까 오늘 피지컬 ai 얘기하려고 그랬는데.
피지컬 ai 이거 장표 한번 좀 보여 드릴게요.
이게 이제 제가 책에서 되게 강조 하고 있는 장표 두 가지 한번 보여
드리면.
좋습니다.
이게 이제 결국에는 이제 우리가 지금 채찌 pt도 생각해보면 ai라고
하는.
인프라는 되게 위에 있는 거고 밑에 있는 여러 가지 인프라를 봤잖아요
.
그런 것처럼 실은 피지컬 ai도 저렇게 일곱 단계 밸류체인이 있어요.
그래서 저 부분을 좀 하나씩 잘 연구를 해보시거나 책을 통해서
보시면 좀 공부가 되실 거고요 .
이것만 외워도 되겠다.
그리고 또 한 가지.
피지컬 ai는 우리 자꾸 로봇만 생각하는데 필컬 ai는 로봇만이
아니라는 거예요.
최근에 진화하고 있는 형태를 보면 우리가 말하는 llm 채찌 pt가 있었
고 그다음에 이제 지금처럼 시각이 생긴 vlm 그래서 그림 그리고 이런
게 있었고.
네.
그래서 우리가 이제 액션을 하는 거죠.
그래서 이제 손을 움직이는 지금 피지컬 ai가 3단계고 4단계는 스스로
가 머릿속에서 시뮬레이션해서 뭔가 공간을 만드는 월드 모델로
갈 건데.
그래서 이런 관점으로 보면 이제 ai가 3.5단계 정도 가고 있고 그런
면에서 이제 이 레이어 같은 걸 좀 공부하면서 보면 마치 이제 3년
전에 채찌 pt 처음 발견하고 우리가 공부하자 할 때 투자했던 사람들이
성공한 것처럼 이제 피지컬 ai도 그런 영역들이 움직이기 시작한다.
공부를 좀 해야겠어.
네.
이거 자세한 내용이 저 피지컬 ai.
근데 이 책에.
이 책에.
열심히 적어놨습니다.
또 있으시는군요.
감사합니다.
누구 피지컬 ai의 과연 게임 체인 저가 될 수 있을까요 피지컬 ai
이미 시작된 미래.
이거 슈가 님이 광고하려면 광고 미 내야 되는데.
아이디어 오늘 발생시켜됐으니까 .
꽁시롱꽁시롱 계속하시면 제가 나중에 뭐라도 하나 해드리도록
하겠습니다.
자 알겠습니다.
고급격 주식방송 주식은 지금.
오늘은 여기까지였습니다.
여러분 감사합니다.
안녕